aucune somme dans un avion oui le
capitaine prend la parole donc vont soir
à tous qu'est ce qui se passe au juge
chantal non parce qu'il me l'avait donné
aussi complet blague alors qu'arras les
cycles de cinq est ce que vous allez la
raconter et après vous vous avez raconté
d'accord
alors est ce qu'on peut faire parce que
vous la connaissez toutes les deux vous
démarrez la blague et elle va la finale
hall et la salle où chacune chacune une
phrase que j'ai commencé à les y donc
nous sommes dans un avion le capitaine
prend la parole d'abord c'est la
capitale et en demandant alors nous aime
dans un avion le commandant prend la
parole
bonsoir je suis votre commandant notre
vol est estimé à 3 heures 30 le ciel et
sera sans turbulence bienvenue à bord
celui-ci coupes sombres ou alors il me
coupe le micro et a parlé aux passagers
un nas teaser 36
il arriverait ne sait plus du tout la
même destination micro a dit bon non
le chanteur tu te trompes tu crois que
mélanie paroisse voilà c'est pour ça que
ça
je suis tout bas s'est passé le site e
tron je peux pas lui prendre la blague
et non attends je te promets crois qu'il
a coupé mika
quand on y est son copilote maintenant
je vais me faire autant ce jeu pisser je
veux pisser je veux
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi tu appliquer cette pas pour
l'acier à la fin tu peux pas faire ça
elle a colonisé là je la tiens est ce
que tu peux nous la terre en entier
ouais ouais mais la fesse les douces
sommes dans un avion il atterrit chez
ruter
[Applaudissements]
décalage horaire oblige mais j'arrive de
roissy ce jour je suis cette blague et
manic j'ai pas dormi de toulouse je vais
la faire courte vous êtes bien à bord du
à 175 ans monsieur j'ai pas le cas bref
bon vol écoute et diesse son copilote et
là je vais pisser après je me dis que
l'hôtesse de l'air est en fait il avait
oublié de couper donc évidemment nous
rêvions d'un blocus de l'air et sur axe
elle commence à courir voir dans le
cockpit et le taper en fait et gagné qu
ils arrêtent et ludiques ou repas il a
dit qu' aller pisser d'abord
[Applaudissements]
c'est la vie non décors peints comme ça
vous auriez fait une petite hésitation
le logo alors moi j'aimerais bien que
gad m'apprenne à raconter une histoire
propre parce que je découvre un univers
fascinant qui est de faire rire les gens
sans dire des saletés relie chantier ah
oui quand les choquer alors ok au jeu
font fait un deal
oui je te prends une propre tu
m'apprends une seule allégation ai dit
papa veut pas de moi 5 euros pour aller
à la piscine
papapapa deux mois 5 euros ball à la
piscine fait qu'outre benjamin as tu
connais le tarif écoute benjamin tu fais
le tarif au non papa me dis pas qu'il
faut encore je te sus le kaki
je tombe des nues seulement battu dès
lors en moi mes parents sont encore
vivants on sait que ça va passer sa
balle est dans la situation dans
laquelle nous ne voulons pas si vite on
a une tonne et un passage je crois non
c'est un couple d'homosexuels ils sont
dans l'avion sur un long courrier
je la dorsale c'est une de mes préférées
il y en a qui disent chalet prends-moi
du pardon tu prends moi j'ai envie
prends-moi minutes avionnais dans un
avion il ya du monde mais c'est un an
courrier tout le monde dort mais les
gens vont se réveiller tu veux je te
montre que personne sur la veille
regarde bien il se lève et crie est ce
que quelqu'un aurait un stylo et dans
l'avion peint bruit tout le monde dort
dit tu vois prends moi lotfi d'accord et
au petit matin à l hôtel est le ps de
l'eure a fait sa tournée et voit une
petite mamie qui grelotte dans son siège
et dit madame vous avez froid dit je
tremble de froid j'ai eu très froid j'ai
eu froid toute la nuit dit mais madame
pourquoi vous n'avez pas réclamer une
couverture fait une couverture cette
nuit y en a un qui a demandé un stylo et
s'est pas engueulé toute l'année
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça parce que ça passe ça passe ça
va quand même la passer en commission un
match est une histoire de deux bugs qui
font un concours masi est le premier qui
réussit à acheter un paquet de
cigarettes le paquet lui offert par
l'autre dans le premier dit à toi donc
la mecque traverse la rue rentrer dans
le bureau de tabac dia à la vendeuse
bonjour madame je voie à un paquet 2
marlboro un jeu wii 10 euros l'histoire
ils y arrivent en quoi il fait que 15
secondes à toi l'hôte arrive en courant
il fait beau jour madame je voudrais à à
un paquet de deux gitanes est lui fait
oui avec ou sans filtre à 100 sans
filtre kaunas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
souhaitant donner une situe la chine
aussi en effet l'argent il ya un hitler
n'est pas mort il vit sur une île
déserte et seulement quelques nazis
savent où il est donc ils viennent le
voir et une vingtaine d'entre eux
faudrait revenir vraiment là c'est le
moment
beaudry dit non non non non non il dit
j'ai merdé une première fois
maintenant je suis tranquille je suis
passé au travail suivirent je suis vieux
laissez moi tranquille il y vraiment non
non ils reviennent à l'aide après ils
sont 200 est vraiment fureur cela aurait
bien que vous reveniez il fait non je
vais déjà dit non je vais j'y vais pas
voilà je suis tranquille et c'est vrai
mais dit il ya urgence je m'en fous
c'est plus mon problème je suis vieux
laissez moi profiter et rien et d'april
sont 2000 mexes à lui tout seul
fureur faut vraiment revenir et dit non
et vous voyez bien regarder années 2000
ils sont nombreux à le demander partout
en europe dans le monde revenait j'ai
réfléchi fait ok mais cette fois ci mais
chambre ok bravo chantal qui m'a relancé
la machine nazie
c'est un mec qui va dans une ferme et il
rencontre quelqu'un qui vend des animaux
et les animaux dit écoutez c'est combien
vous lui demandez combien les les poules
il va à droite toutes ces poules là que
tu vois à droite là celle-là c'est 10
euros
par contre celle que tu vois la gauche
là celle-là c'est 10 euros comprend pas
il commence avec continuer à marcher
tout est dit et les moutons là tu les
vois combien et il va tout ce que tu
vois la droite l'a tous ces moutons là
c'est 50 euros par contre tout ce que tu
vois à gauche là où cela c'est 50 euros
nasri comprend pas et tous et continuez
tout ils voient ils voient des chevaux
et tout est dit et les chevaux célébrant
combien il y va tous les chevaux que tu
vois là cela c'est 2000 euros par contre
tout ce que tu vois à gauche là c'est
2000 euros dim pas quoi je comprends pas
depuis tout à l'heure je visite à faire
mais tu me dis que tout ce que tu as à
droite coûte le même prix en fait que
tout ce que tu as à gauche il dit ouais
parce qu'en fait tout ce que j'ai à
droite c'est à moi par contre tout ce
que j'ai à gauche ça moi aussi mais moi
en français
la salle arena pauli alors c'est au
paradis et saint-pierre donc et avec
dieu comme ça il les accueille dix
femmes qui sont mortes le même jour et
est donc st pierre dit que celles qui
ont trompé leurs maris avance d'un pas
et là donc il ya 9 femmes qui font un
pas en avant comme ça et on a une qui
reste comme ça et saint pierre se
retourne vers du edit bon et maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de la sourde
[Applaudissements]
c'est demain qui s'empare ya vraiment
deux potes ils sont variés bois mort
puis bouaflé coup bien des [ __ ]
seront chier je vois encore rentré bourg
et ma femme va encore m'engueuler comme
tous les soirs ils sont peu 10 mai à la
raison que je l'étais con comme une pile
franchement une solution pour quelle
gueule pas moi je le fais chez moi est
ce que toi je sais comment tu rends tu
rentres tu es beau petit tube tu
farfouille dans la serrure qui fait des
bouts et allume tout tu renverses les
vols arrivent dans la chambre tu allumes
tout tu te réveilles heigl méfie pour
une fois avant de rentrer tueur espère
un grand coup qui choisit bien taclé tu
fais pas d'erreur tu fais pas de bruit
tu n'a lui même rien tu ne bouscule pas
les meubles tu te glisse doucement tu te
déshabille doucement tu te glisse dans
le lit et tu bouffes le cutoff tu ne
rend 40 roche
tu pourras même allé dans le frigo de
prendre une bière elle te [ __ ] à
l'appel mais qui dit ouais c'est génial
ça s'arrose ils reçoivent des coups bas
il arrive chez lui à 3 heures du mat
sais pas respire un grand coup il a 4
grammes tout à fait qu'est ce qui vous
inspire est bien choisir la clé bien
chose avec les rangs doucement de rien à
limay devront repérer les mom de patti
tube est rentré dans la chambre
doucement se déshabiller se glisser dans
le lit et là ils bouffent le cul de sa
femme qui dort profondément bout d'une
demi heure rien et trois quarts d'heure
il commence à avoir mal emballé choir et
tous les mineurs ils entendent petits
couinements et ouais c'est bon ça
commence à chauffer une heure et demie
une explosion sous la couette enfin le
mec il est tout temps qu'il ose et hélas
il prend la couette et il va dans la
cuisine boire sa bière qui l'a bien
mérité et là il va dans la cuisine il
allume et voit sa femme qui boit un café
dans l'accueil des mais qu'est ce que tu
fais là pas loin furia maman qui dort
dans la chambre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un gars qui que ça c'est un gars
qui rentre tous les soirs chez lui et
bourré il enlève ses pompes fait prendre
la 1ère et la jette contre l'amour pas
la deuxième le voisin il n'en peut plus
il en peut plus tous les instants le
voisin vient le voir édition moi
j'habite à côté je suis enseignant je me
lève à 6h du mat
tous les matins ses deux chaussures je
ne vois plus et je sois beau ya pas de
problème ces bons plans de my hand in on
aime toujours au même point deuxième il
appose tout doucement par terre elles
ont attiré ni s'il te plaît jette la
deuxième fait quelque chose
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais qu'est chez lui devant un match de
foot et il ya sa femme tu pourrais m'en
mener une bière avant que ça commence me
plaît alors là fameux wii et prend une
bière à lui amène ça me tape réfléchir
youtube tu peuvent amener une deuxième
bien avant que ça commence
ça fait d'accord prend une bière à lui
amène avec boit sa bière à ça car il
fait bon l'amour est une bien avant que
ça commence à fait on peut pas bouger
ton qu un peu effet voilà ça commence
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai eu une mais je suis pas serein
du tout alors tu peux y aller la favela
bâti une visuel déjà faut faire un petit
exercice de mémoire donc je montre ça
faut retenir bien c'est donc là quite
red wings en eau not ok je sais que gaga
tu fais ça tu as bien retenu les quatre
bah oui sans faute bienvenue à tous et
messmer
c'est un peu ça fait de vrai mentaliste
un manoir attend donc maintenant ce que
tu vas faire tu vas me répéter trois
fois de suite genre tatata la couleur en
bas à droite vas-y trois fois de suite
green jin jing allo
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]